in addition to the economic uncertainty
caused by the coronavirus a big part of
the decision on when to reduce
mitigation efforts has to do with
knowing who is immune in the first place
or dr. David agus joins us from Los
Angeles with new information on that
good morning to you David we've been
hearing a lot about this antibody test
it's been getting a lot of news lately
so first tell us what kind of test is it
and what exactly will it show so this is
a blood test that shows if you have had
in the past tense coronavirus so about
50% of people are up to 50 percent who
have coronavirus don't even know they
have it they have no symptoms so it's
critical that we get an accurate number
of the people in the country who've
actually been exposed or had to the
virus and it will tell us if they're
immune if they can't get it again and
they can't spread it to others so if you
have the antibodies how long are you
immune that's the million-dollar
question is that we don't know this
virus has only been studied since
mid-december so we don't know out
whether it's going to be a year two
years or five years my gut is if you
have enough antibodies in the tests you
have at least a year of immunity after
that we're just gonna learn as we go
you know David this this virus does seem
to be a moving target you know I heard
somebody give the analogy it's like
learning to fly the plane while you're
flying the plane is that a good analogy
to describe with what we're dealing with
here it's an apt analogy certainly I
mean this is all new right every virus
when it comes has evolved and it's a new
entity we don't know how it behaves we
don't know how to treat it we don't know
how to prevent it we don't even know how
infectious it is we're learning that
it's more effective than we actually
thought so we're in a new area now that
you know every time we see a patient
we're learning something about the virus
my hope and prayers are we're sharing
all the data so we can all learn
together so the thing about the antibody
test if you get it you want it test
positive because it shows that you've
had it and and if once it shows that
you've had it what good what can we do
with that information
how will this help lessen things up
about when we can go back outside again
well it's a critical test it's a test
where they're now many available but
most of them across the country that are
available are not very good so it's
critical that don't get one yet the new
ones that should work well we're told
will be out later this week but it says
whether you can no longer get the virus
and you can't spread the virus so this
is going to be a certificate of immunity
if you will where you can go back to
work without worrying you could be
exposed to somebody with the virus and
not worry about catching it you can care
for somebody with the virus and not
catch it yourself that's critically
important when we do policy in the
United States yeah and this also sounds
like a test everybody should get since
you can have the virus and not have the
symptoms correct it's not should get
will get we have to test the whole
country in order to open the country you
have to know your status so you can know
how to behave and you can know your own
risk factors before we open up the
country all right thank you very much
dr. David agus thanks